[Musique]
bienvenue en direct de l'Université des
maires de l'Ouest parisien et je reçois
Gérard Larcher bonjour bonjour président
du Sénat et lui disait d'ailleurs Kiki
la personnalité qui vient que vous êtes
fidèle c'est université c'est le
président du Sénat ou c'est l'élu des
Yvelines les deux
l'élu des Yvelines à la rencontre des
mers des Yvelines et le président du
Sénat la rencontre
l'élu des élus des Yvelines des élus des
Hauts-de-Seine et j'allais dire c'est
dans ces deux fonctions
demain par exemple je serai avec les
mers ruraux du Lot-et-Garonne
vendredi dernier j'ai été avec les mers
du Puy de Dôme et la semaine d'avant
j'étais à l'assemblée générale des mers
de Seine-et-Marne vous voyez que ça
c'est le contact nécessaire entre un
lieu où on fait la loi on représente les
collectivités territoriales et puis les
réalités que les maires vivent vivent
devant nous
budgétaire de mobilité
la réalité de la crise énergétique tout
ça et je ne vous cache pas qu'à chaque
fois je fais remonter aux commissions et
notamment la commission des finances les
observations que j'entends parce que je
pense qu'en permanence il faut être dans
le territoire d'ailleurs la Constitution
le dit le Sénat est une chambre légitime
évidemment mais la Constitution dit elle
représente les collectivités
territoriales c'est très important bien
sûr la représentation des collectivités
24 bis et c'est pour ça que le président
du Sénat est aussi tous mes collègues
sénateurs
s'immerge vraiment dans le territoire au
contact des 35 000 communes des plus de
100 départements et collectivités
territoriales des 17 régions alors il y
a peut-être un mot derrière tout ça et
et vous avez lancé un
groupe de recherche de travail sur ce
thème c'est le mot décent vous êtes
partisan à ce qui est un nouveau pas de
la décentralisation il Sénat commence à
travailler dessus pourquoi déjà pour
pourquoi il faut ce nouveau pas sur la
décentralisation nous avions présenté en
2020 un rapport j'allais dire 30 groupes
politiques du groupe communiste au
groupe les républicains
et il y avait 50 propositions pour les
collectivités territoriales et nous les
avions présenté proposé d'ailleurs au
président de la République puisqu’en
2019 à l'issue de la crise des gilets
jaunes le président de la République
avait dit bah il faut que nous ayons une
nouvelle étape dans la décentralisation
c'est pas passé grand chose à
l'exception deux textes notamment la loi
3DS seulement qui a été adopté sur
lequel
le Sedat a fait beaucoup de choses que
ce soit pour les communes urbaines et
ces rues que ce soit pour la relation
commune Intercommun côté et qui ont
repris 10 propositions des 50 que
faisait le Sénat le président de la
République vient de dire qu'il était
favorable à une grande loi des
centralisations alors le Sénat est
disponible et le Sénat se met au travail
c'est un travail permanent mais nous
avons mis en place le 5 octobre donc la
semaine dernière
le groupe de travail ce groupe
transgroupe bien sûr qui reprend avec
trois grands sujets
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
territoriales c'est pas la peine de
parler de décentralisation voilà si les
communes n'ont aucune autonomie
financière et on voit aujourd'hui les
difficultés avec dans lesquelles j'étais
avec des maires des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine qui faisaient maire de
communes rurale maire de communion
urbaine maire de très grandes communes
la réalité de leur budget en matière
d'énergie de restauration scolaire de
matières premières de pression aussi
sur les centres communaux d'action
sociale la réalité par exemple des
charges des charges locatives qui sont
appelées notamment dans le parc social
et le parc social ancien vont pouvoir
payer les loyers des HLM en gros de la
proximité des communes et quelque chose
d'essentiel donc ça c'est le premier
point
second sujet c'est la différenciation
est-ce qu'on traite de la même manière
des territoires
qui sont des territoires ruraux est-ce
qu'on traite de la même manière l'Ariège
et les Yvelines est-ce qu'on traite de
la même manière
des réalités que je vivais dans dans le
Puy-de-Dôme avec des agriculteurs
les mêmes réalités puis le troisième
sujet il peut pas y avoir de
décentralisation vous savez c'est pas la
décentralisation pour la
décentralisation c'est la
décentralisation pour la proximité pour
recréer de la confiance et aussi pour
faire en proximité ce qu'on fait mieux
en proximité qu'on le fait de manière
bretonne vous savez depuis 15 ans
en tous les cas depuis 10 ans on a
vraiment recentralisé on a verticalisé
en arrière on est revenu en arrière
c'est vrai et les grandes lois sous
Mitterrand il y a décentralisation ça
veut dire aussi un état territorial
n'est à local fort là pourquoi nous
appelons ça la déconcentration et très
on peut pas parler de couple mère préfet
si le préfet n'a aucun pouvoir sur ses
services nous voulons impérativement
retrouver on l'a fait à tout petit bout
dans 3ds sur les questions de de l'eau
ou de la biodiversité il faut qu'on
aille beaucoup plus loin en fait il faut
que l'État centrale fasse confiance à
l'état territorial et on a vu notamment
dans la crise du covid comment les les
collectivités territoriales sont agir là
où les femmes ne savaient pas faire
elles sont une souplesse on a bien fait
quand on l'a fait ensemble mais il faut
pas oublier le rôle des collectivités
territoriales je ne pose pas l'État les
collectivités territoriales nous avons
besoin les uns des autres est-ce que
vous direz qu'il y a aussi dans cette
espoir de décentralisation un enjeu
démocratique
c'est la proximité nous voyons bien que
plus on est vertical
moins les citoyens le sentiment d'être
entendu écouter et moins il participe et
c'est un vrai sujet pour nous tous quel
que soit notre sensibilité
l'abstention
l'abstention c'est j'allais dire le
premier adversaire d'une vie
démocratique qui est saine or la
proximité le débat vous savez on fait
des grandes théories sur
la
démocratie participative la première
démocratie participative c'est ce que
fait un conseil municipal quand il va
faire des réunions de quartier quand sur
un projet il va échanger avec les
citoyens et ça n'est pas toujours facile
parce que d'ailleurs dans ce type de
réunion on rend le maire responsable de
tout comme en fait
c'est l'élu qui a porté de vif
parce que parfois j'ai pire que que cela
et je dois dire je vais prendre un
exemple quand on parle de politique de
transport qui
dépendent pour certaines politiques de
transport de la région d'autres de
l'État vous savez quand à bailli noisy
noisy il y a un problème de bruit c'est
le maire absolument voir et je dois dire
qu'il faut qu'on apporte des réponses
mais là ça nécessite ce partenariat mais
les citoyens ils reconnaissent d'abord
leur mère parce que quelque part
c'est leur avocat c'est loin un mot
justement sur cette question de la
démocratie et puis des pouvoirs locaux
on reparle beaucoup de revenir sur le
non-cumul des mandats il y a eu une
proposition d'un sénateur du sénateur
Marseille au Sénat il y a carloli qui
fait cette même député qui est à
l'Assemblée est-ce que vous avez une
position là-dessus je pense que ça a été
une erreur et une erreur manifeste de
mettre un peu hors-sol et dans le riche
du hors sol les parlementaires et que
donc exercé un mandat exécutif local et
à mandat parlementaire c'est au
contraire recréer du lien voilà pourquoi
la première proposition de loi qui a eu
lieu elle était au Sénat elle était du
président du groupe des radicaux radical
de gauche chaque Mézard nous l'avions
distribué qui a été ministre et qui est
maintenant membre du Conseil constitué
c'est Hervé Marseille qui a fait adopter
une proposition de loi l'an dernier et
le président du groupe de l'Union
centriste et il est élu des
Hauts-de-Seine et car l'olive l'ancien
maire de Poissy a déposé une proposition
de loi il a pas encore pu la déposer
nous en avons partagé ensemble je crois
que c'est de salut public démocratique
de faire avancer ces textes
je voudrais qu'on dise un mot peut-être
de la métropole du Grand Paris alors
voilà on en entend parler depuis la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozy on a
l'impression qu'il y a pas grand chose
qui se fait qu'on sait pas très bien
comment tous articuler avec la région
avec les départements avec les grandes
villes vous allez vous en parler un peu
de ce sujet non oui c'est d'abord son
étant paré puisque dans les 50
propositions nous avions dit que sur la
question des métropoles il fallait
apporter des réponses il y a encore au
Sénat
une mission d'évaluation de la
commission des lois sur la
fonctionnement des métropoles de Lyon et
de Marseille qui rencontre un certain
nombre de difficultés vous savez quand
vous êtes à la métropole de Lyon et que
vous avez
42 mers sur plus de 57 qui veulent
quitter la métropole c'est qu'il y a un
problème
à Marseille le problème aujourd'hui
quel est le pouvoir entre les communes
et la métropole et des sujets financiers
majeurs pour la métropole qu'on appelle
du Grand Paris de l'Île-de-France je
prends le sujet globalement c'est un des
sujets dont le groupe de travail
c'est emparé et qu'il mettra lors du
jour pour vous donner un agenda rapport
d'état au mois de janvier prochain et
rapport définitif je pense fin mars
début avril donc on n'est pas dans des
choses très lointaines un mot peut-être
de du sida et de la politique nationale
c'est vrai que le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
renforce le rôle du Sénat dans le
travail législatif comment vous le voyez
ce rôle du sida plutôt
d'opposition parce que après tout il y a
une majorité d'opposition au Sénat au
plus tôt de travail de conciliation de
réconciliation parce que peut-être un
besoin de la médiation de la France
d'abord le bicabéris c'est quoi
pour reprendre une formule d'un de mes
maîtres l'Assemblée nationale c'est la
pulsion le Sénat c'est un balancier
stabilisateur des institutions donc
par nature et même quand la majorité
c'est l'intérieur et de la même
sensibilité que la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai connu ça à ma
première président du Sénat
notre rôle de contre-pouvoir notre
indépendance c'est une qualité me
semble-t-il
utile à la République la seconde des
choses c'est que nous sommes un lieu de
dialogue et dans ce lieu de dialogue
naturellement nous dialoguons avec les
députés mais nous devons dialoguer aussi
avec les collectivités territoriales et
donc
d'autres démarches est une démarche en
responsabilité quel que soit le groupe
quand on dit non c'est non je vais
prendre exemple quand le président de la
République nous a proposé
il y a pas si longtemps de réformer la
Constitution à la suite de la convention
citoyenne nous étions hostile à la
modification de la Constitution pour
introduire des clauses des clauses
constitutionnelles en matière
environnementale non pas parce que nous
considérons pas que c'est ce n'est pas
une priorité que la transition
écologique mais nous pensons que la
rédaction nous conduisait à des blocages
futurs que déjà Jacques Chirac avait
introduit le principe de précaution
forte heureusement on va voir à débat
sur le nucléaire vous imaginez si on
avait modifié la Constitution qu'il
aurait été donc aujourd'hui notre ligne
de crête c'est l'intérêt du pays notre
ligne de crête c'est aussi des valeurs
que nous portons dans la MA qui est
diverses qui est diverses mais vraiment
c'est l'état d'esprit qui est l'autre si
on regarde un peu le paysage de la
France aujourd'hui on voit quand même
une France un peu désespéré un peu
pessimiste
quelle peut être le rôle des élus
justement pour essayer de redonner le
moral au français quoi
il y a une trappe il remplaçable dans
notre pays qui s'appelle le plus de 500
000 élus territoriaux souvenez-vous
dans les années
2012-2013 2014 on disait il y a trop
d'élus moi je pense que la République a
besoin de ses élus et que ces 500 000
élus territoriaux sont quelque part les
représentants des citoyens voilà
pourquoi nous nous sommes élus au
suffrage universel indirect mais que au
travers de ces 500 000 élus qui notre
corps électoral quelque part c'est les
citoyens que nous représentons et donc
le rôle pour redonner le moral au pays
c'est là la proximité je dis pas que ça
suffit mais je dis que la
décentralisation c'est un des leviers du
retour de la confiance car le premier
grand sujet c'est le sujet de la
confiance nous sommes dans une société
de défiance dans une société qui se
replie les uns par rapport aux autres et
il faut qu'on trouve des lieux où on
forme communauté ou singulier la
première des communautés c'est la
commune merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité
et à TV
78 la chaîne des Yvelines
par tour voilà et bonne universités
[Musique]